three-headed metal dragons and an
all-out assault on Hong Kong these high
octane Robo brawls transform the series
into something great the first scene of
Transformer action in the series is also
one of the best
it has to be it's a moment in 2007's
Transformers that the Decepticons decide
the importance of finding the all-spark
outweighs the cast of remaining hidden
it's also the first time that humans
become aware of robots into Skies among
us but you can call us Autobots for
short otherwise
what starts outers are stressful but
believably human encounter between the
US Military and an unidentified
helicopter quickly turns into a huge
battle between the service members of a
Qatar base and the Decepticon blackout
there's heavy gunfire rockets and an
alien concussion weapon that sends a
shockwave through the entire base
smashing glass and sending soldiers
flying Revenge of the Fallen introduces
a number of new Autobots and Decepticons
over the course of the movie and this
major battle shows them go head to head
with one another but what's most
exciting about this action sequence is
the smaller scale battle within a battle
that bumblebee has with Decepticons
Rampage and ravage bumblebee is
protecting Shia LaBeouf's Sam Megan Fox
Says Michaela and Sam's parents from an
attack by Rampage meanwhile ravage who's
taken the form of a big cat attempts a
sneak attack but bumblebee is too quick
and literally rips a smaller robot's
spine out Revenge of the Fallen opens
with nests and the Autobots traveling to
Shanghai to find Decepticons hiding out
on Earth Demolisher a giant Transformer
comes to life and immediately begins to
destroy everything it can reach Optimus
Prime is dropped from a carrier plane
and attacks just as Demolisher destroys
an overburst Optimus easily brings down
the Giants Decepticon but his
destructive run has already taken a toll
on the city while offering fans one of
the most exciting actions scenes in the
franchise
the sequence starts off on the top floor
of a skyscraper one being toppled by the
invading Decepticons unfortunately our
human heroes are at the very top and the
real excitement comes when they decide
it's time to escape from an armed robot
they leap out of the windows of the
Leaning skyscraper and begin to slide
down the edge of the building at
Breakneck speed Tyrese Gibson Sergeant
Epps has the idea to shoot out the glass
of the windows the heroes are sliding
down so that they can re-enter the
building but when they fall back inside
they just start sliding across the floor
in the opposite direction as the
building's lean turns more into a
full-on fall the characters desperately
grab at whatever is around all while
avoiding falling off his objects and
while most survive some plummet to their
death
this Revenge of the Fallen scene begins
when a group of trucks and construction
vehicles Converge on a sandpit with
human characters Simmons and Leo
watching nervously the multiple Vehicles
begin to transform with these
decepticons are known as the
Constructicons beginning to form one
gigantic Transformer the Kaiju size
Devastator doesn't even allow Simmons
and Leo to be scared of how big it is
before it begins its first attack
it creates an extremely powerful vacuum
in its mouth that draws sand from the
desert and every nearby vehicle into its
gaping more and when the cars enter its
mouth they're crushed and explode out of
Devastators back in a plume full of fire
and smoke towards the end of
Transformers climatic battle and Mission
City bumblebee has been seriously
wounded and has lost his legs but
Michaela is quick to act and hooks his
torso up to a tow truck and gets them
both to Safety in an alley but that
safety only lasts a moment as Michaela
kicks the tow truck into high gear and
speeds back out into The Fray only
stopping for a quick moment to turn back
to Bumblebee and say
I'll Thrive you shoot
it's one of the best lines on the
franchise and it leads to one of the
best Human Transformer action moments in
all of the movies Michaela drives
backwards so that bumblebee can face his
enemies and together the two Russia
Decepticon the human soldiers are unable
to bring down as they drive bumblebee
unloads almost the entire arsenal of his
weapons but more than that he has to
move the destroyed cars in the street
out of their way leading to some classic
Michael Bay car flips that are such a
small part of the larger action here
they just feel like Grace knows in Age
of Extinction entrepreneurs Stanley
Tucci's Joshua Joyce discovers
transformium can be programmed not only
that after mapping its genome it can be
given instruction by humans the first
action scene we get to see with the
newly human program Transformers
Galvatron and Stinger is a massive
highway chase Galvatron and Stinger are
sent after the Autobots by Joyce and his
company but they soon begin to act on
their own and Destroy cars driven by
innocent civilians for fun while
engaging the Autobots but the real
excitement is a way to transform
chromium allows these new robots to
transform and reform their
Transformations are fluid almost as if
they turn into a metallic liquid made up
of tiny shards between vehicle and robot
form when bumblebee fires a series of
shots that perfectly connect with
Galvatron the transformium robot
explodes into bits of metal before
simply performing as a vehicle behind
Bumblebee early in the last night Mark
Wahlberg's Katie agar searches the ruins
of the aftermath of the battle of
Chicago for any Autobot survivors and is
attacked by the newly formed
Transformers reaction force AKA trf they
have him surrounded and things don't
look good but bumblebee comes rushing
onto the scene in car form leaps over a
hail of bullet fire from the trf members
transforms and falls apart he lands on
the ground in the middle of the trf
soldiers in several pieces but it only
takes a second before he goes on the
offensive with those disparate limbs
almost every single passive is
disarticulated body attacking
individually at the same time he begins
to reassemble all the while it's a great
sequence that adds a new attack option
for one of the most beloved Autobots
um bumblebee we only met when I was a
little boy in short pants that must have
been that tall maybe taller or maybe
shorter I can't remember in Age of
Extinction as a battle rages in Hong
Kong Optimus to size that they need
reinforcements he goes to the ship that
contains some legendary Warriors the
Dinobot and wakes them up in hopes that
they will join the fights for the
Autobots but they don't immediately jump
at the chance to serve as allies and
instead Optimus takes them on proving
that he can beat them and is a leader
worthy of their allegiance it's an
incredible fight scene not only because
we get to finally see the Dinobots in
action in both dinosaur and robot form
but also because their scale is
astounding Optimus a very large robot by
most measurements is a fraction of the
size of these legendary Transformers
after the Hong Kong Battle Turns the
Autobots way there's a brief moment for
celebration but then lockdown arrives
the Bounty Hunter's massive ship opens a
strange looking weapon that begins to
draw all metal objects towards it but
it's not just small metal objects it's
literally everything from the beams
within buildings to entire cars and
boats a giant magnet leads to a
widespread destruction that's only made
worse when the heroes realize that it's
not just picking up all the metal in the
city it's alternating between lifting
and dropping these objects causing
massive shipping boats to rain from the
sky drawing all this chaos the movie
focuses on our human Heroes who are in a
car attempting to not get sucked up into
the magnet is the source of Chase
sequence but instead of being chased by
another vehicle or another Transformer
our lead characters are trying to escape
death and destruction by magnet the
Transformers franchise isn't known for
its emotional heft but sometimes those
over-the-top action scenes can hit you
in the fields such as a fight between
Nemesis Prime and Bumblebee in the last
night Optimus has been brainwashed by
the powerful Transformer quintessa and
renamed Nemesis Prime as he serves her
wishes at one point bumblebee pursues
his former leader and engages him in a
fight on a resurfacing ship in the
middle of the ocean the fight between
Bumblebee and Nemesis is simultaneously
thrilling and heartbreaking as we know
these two have great love for one
another and shouldn't be set against
each other their fight is brutal and the
sequence has only made more exciting and
emotionally difficult to watch as Cade
places himself in the middle of the
fight and attempts to draw out the real
Optimus he would never fight his old
friend I am bumblebee your oldest friend
after our Heroes made that skyscraper
jump in Dark of the Moon Decepticon
Shockwave notices that there are still
survivors in the skyscraper so he calls
on his trusted enforcer driller to take
down the rest of the building driller is
a huge snake-like Decepticon with one
massive cylindrical central body and
several tendrils that he uses to break
things apart in its path driller
immediately gets to work tearing through
the lower levels of the building it
looks as if it's swimming like a flying
fish coming up and down through the
glass of the building but soon it begins
to change its approach and starts to
ensnare the building in a massive
constriction at the point where it was
already beginning to lean the
construction breaks the final hold of
the building and brings it perpendicular
with itself before driller makes a final
attack on the building
after Cemetery win the tax Kate's Family
Farm while searching for Optimus Cade is
daughter Tess their friend Lucas and
Tessa's secret boyfriend Shane tried to
escape while being pursued by military
grade Vehicles a Chase takes them
through cornfields backyards a small
nearby town and finally an abandoned
Factory Lots at extreme speeds along
with the requisite car flips and a
thrilling high-speed lead from an upper
story of the factory onto a ramp below
the final moments of the chase are
parallel by a fight between Optimus
Prime and lockdown the fight takes them
over the rooftops of the factory lot and
includes Optimus making use of a crane
to ensnare and hang lockdown but perhaps
the most visually exciting moment comes
when Optimus block sour human heroes
from their pursuers where essentially
Barrel rolling over the cemetery wins
cars the last night open for the
medieval battle that we learned
Transformers assisted in and the story
centers on finding a wizard staff so
that the world can be saved let those
who exist long after a snow
that this was our finest hour
the most exciting part of the more
fantasy leaning last night visually at
least is the inclusion of dragonstorm
dragonstorm is a huge three-headed metal
dragon formed by the combining of the
Knights of ayakan Guardian Knights of
the staff of Merlin the knights form
into this glorious Dragon form in the
finale of the last night to participate
in the aerial battle that takes place
over under and between the colliding
Cybertron and Earth planets the fight
between Optimus Prime Sentinel Prime and
Megatron in the final moments of Dark of
the Moon Remains the most brutal fight
in the entire series the sequence begins
with a thrilling fight between Optimus
and Sentinel whose betrayed as Autobot
comrades to work with the Decepticons
but just when things look most Bleak for
Optimus and Sentinel is about to strike
a killing blow Megatron opens fire on
Sentinel as Megatron beats Sentinel
Optimus returns to his feet and when
Megatron suggests the truce Optimus rips
his head in spinal cord from the rest of
his body using his ax as Megatron's
Parts disconnect there's a spray of
Sparks and fluid that's essentially
Transformer blood
but that's not the end of the scene as
Optimus then turns his attention to
Sentinel and quite literally kills him
execution Style with a shotgun blast to
the Head
[Music]